after more than a month under
government-imposed closure the shutters
are starting to be raised Europe is
taking its first cautious steps out of
lockdown many Italian book shops
stationery stores and children's
clothing shops were allowed to reopen on
Tuesday albeit with strict conditions
but in a country which has seen more
than 20,000 fatalities from the virus
the relief is mixed with fear I think
the right thing is to prevent every
possibility of infection obviously one
needs to balance this with the need for
normal life to resume but always
remembering that the risk is still very
high it's better to be alive and poor if
the shops that reopen are totally safe
for both workers and customers then I am
in favor I worry that there will be a
lot to do to get to that stage though
Italy is not made up of just large
companies with big spaces that can
easily be organized shops in Austria are
also reopening for the first time since
mid-march and all those shoppers are
being urged not to Stampede to the sales
there is a sense of optimism among
Vienna's retailers yeah yes actually
we're in good spirits the people have
been locked up until now we have already
received some requests by phone and
email people are in the mood for some
addresses yes we're hopeful once a token
Indian nigs our approach over the coming
months is going to be very clear as much
freedom as possible as much restriction
as necessary but let me add should the
figures develop in the wrong direction
we will of course pull the emergency
brake which we have in place should it
become necessary accurate data is
crucial in knowing how and when to apply
that emergency brake
the virus is ripping through the
continents care homes where elderly
residents are particularly vulnerable to
infection but in the UK the government's
daily death and infection statistics
only include hospital patients a new
data suggests the real totals are much
larger
care home providers say the suggestion
that UK government statistics are under
estimating coronavirus death
by some 15% themselves under estimates
hc1 one of Britain's largest operating
329 homes including the one behind me
say the virus is now present in
two-thirds of its residences and that
the deaths of one third of its residents
in the past three weeks have involved
coronavirus that's more than 300 people
Britons coronavirus restrictions are
being reviewed this week with the
decision by Thursday on the current
evidence there's no possibility that the
UK will be joining Italy Austria and
Spain in starting to lift its
coronavirus confinement orders Paul
Brennan al Jazeera sorry